WAS COMING.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT
MA
FOURTH LINE WITH LUCIC AND
RITCHIE.
THE OTHER GUY HE TRUSTS GAME.
>> SCHMALTZ AND KELLER GETLAY FO
START.
>> NICK SCHMALTZ LOOKING FOR THE
20TH OF THE
GAME.
>> ARIZONA WINS IS NICK RITCHIE.
IN THIS CASE GOALS IN THE 12
GAMES SIN
FLAMES TRYING TO TURN THE HEAT
UP WITH FIVE AND A HALF GON FACE
OFF.
>> THAT PUCK WAS LOOSE.
THE WHISTLE DIDN'T GO FOR
GOOD WIDE PASS D TO D
SURVEYS.
BACK TO ONE AND ABLE ANDERSSON .
AND THE PLAY THERE.
HE LEAVES THE POST THINKING
'S W.
ANDERSSON UNABLE TO ELEVATE.
>> FLAMES POWERER
SEE HIM UP ON THE TOP OF JOHNNY
GAUDREAU.
AND HIGH TO LOW AND TO NET.
AND
KELLER.
DROPS IT OFF. REBOUND STOPPED BY
MARKSTROM.
HE CAME ICE.
GOSTISBEHERE LOST AN EDGE. PICKD
APART
LUCIC TAKES A LOOK IN
DIAGNOSTICS.
THE OFFICIAL MEDICAL
THREE PLAYERS ON THE LINE
REUNITED IN THE SECOND PERIOD
TO KEEP IT 3-0.
>> AND MANGIAPANE JUST MAKES
NIKITA ZADOROV GOES JAY
BEAGLE AND RECOGNIZE JAY BEAGLE
IS A PHYSICAL GUYGAMES AGAINST
EACH OTHER.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY WANTS TO
MAKE SURE A
GOOD SAVE BY VEJMELKA.
TKACHUK DID A GOOD JOB TO GET
THE SHOT AWAY TOIEVABLE SAVE BY
VEJMELKA.
AND READS THE PLAY.
WATCHH PERFORMANCE.
BUT HE ALSO IS COMING BACK FROM
HIP SURGERY AND MULTIPLE OFF THD
INTO THE BACK OF
INTERESTING PLAY.
TKACHUK WAS DOWN AND OUT ANDH 1N
THE THIRD.
>>